so today i am going to be
discussing what compassion fatigue is
and how we can recognize it
who's at risk and why we should care
about it
and then what can we do about it
including some
you know i ideas about educating people
in our field about it
some strategies for combating it
so first let's define the term
um compassion fatigue is an emotional
and
physical burden that's created by the
trauma of helping others in distress
which then leads to a reduced capacity
for empathy towards suffering in the
future
and a term that's also been applied to
it is the cost of caring
and that was coined by dr charles figly
who's a researcher in the field of
traumatology
and psychology and he was one of the
first researchers
to define this idea and it's associated
with specific professions
ones that provide care to living
creatures so that would be
human and veterinary health care mental
health care workers social workers
of course also animal research so the
connections that we form
with those that we're taking care of and
repetitive
empathic responses to them can cause us
to kind of
burn out emotionally and this makes us
uh makes us unable or more difficult to
deal with stresses in our lives
both inside and outside of work and
the most insidious aspect of compassion
fatigue i think is that it really
attacks the core
of what brings people into these fields
which is their
empathy and compassion towards animals
and humans
so there's a couple other terms that you
may find in the literature surrounding
this topic so i wanted to bring them up
here secondary traumatic stress is
exposure to knowledge about a
traumatizing event
that's experienced by another so it's a
pretty active
description of compassion fatigue so
what they've found over time is that
family members and counselors and
people that provide care to those that
um
to traumatize individuals will actually
start showing similar signs to the
actual traumatized individuals
themselves
and then this was described as secondary
traumatic stress and dr charles figly
later
described it as compassion fatigue as
well and so these terms are kind of
interchangeable
and you might also see vicarious trauma
and secondary victimization
in the literature as well
now some of you may have also heard the
term burnout
and it's sometimes used in relation to
compassion fatigue but i do want to
point out that it is
different any person in any career can
experience burnout
it's really defined as what occurs um
in when a person is experiencing too
much stress or
pressure and gets too few few sources of
satisfaction in their work environment
so it's really related to kind of the
external work environment so things like
your salary and how much you get paid
and how far away you have to travel um
and you know vacation time
so it's especially a problem if somebody
is stressed at work
but they don't feel a sense of
appreciation for what they're doing as
well so burnout
can be treated by changing your
environment so
getting a new job in a new environment
can actually solve it
but if someone's experiencing compassion
fatigue and they get a new job
it's not going to fix the problem
so compassion fatigue is associated with
the specific work that we do
so um so as i said leaving is not going
to fix the problem but since burnout
does definitely contribute to compassion
fatigue
and some definitions actually state that
capacity is a combination of secondary
traumatic stress and burnout together
um you can get some short-term benefits
from changing jobs
but if you're staying in the same field
still working with animals providing
care to animals
um you can continue to have the same
problems in a new work environment
now a way that i like to think about
capacity i like this analogy that
it's our emotional resources and
compassion are like a bank so if we keep
making withdrawals
without under deposit soon we're going
to be empty
and it affects your job your personal
and professional relationships and even
your physical health
so if compass fatigue is the cost of
caring than what maybe is
the payment there's a term that's used
called compassion satisfaction
and this is when people feel really
invigorated and happy by the work that
they do they feel successful
so if you're drawing out of your
emotional bank constantly but you can
find ways
to fill it again
then you can potentially improve your
compassion fatigue signs and you'll stop
feeling such a harsh effects of cash
fatigue
so as we continue to talk about ways to
combat this we'll be touching on
basically ways that we improve our
compassion satisfaction
now since our job in this field does
usually require
caring for animals and of course the
answer to this problem is to not
not feel compassion at all how do we
overcome this
so i think the first step is really kind
of what i'm doing right now is
educating those in our field about it
and bringing awareness to the issue
in our industry i think it's been pretty
common to not discuss the emotional
aspects of our jobs
and not talk about the potential
emotional trauma this can cause
so bringing awareness to the idea that
it is normal and it's okay is really
important
and then then you need to learn coping
strategies which can include
self-care techniques positive
connections with our jobs and also
appropriate outlets for grief and so
i'll be discussing all of these
throughout the presentation
so now that we all kind of know what
compact fatigue is who's at risk of it
kind of makes sense that people whose
job description directly involves
working with
animals would be at risk so you know
your veterinary staff
and animal care technicians and then of
course your research staff
and you know your pis but also your
icook staff
and other administrative staff they do
have a risk so if you think about how
i cook category e you know like protocol
review and if they're
looking at a lot of category e protocols
they still are experiencing and thinking
about
animals experiencing these protocols and
so over time that can lead to compass
fatigue and
as well and even are just plain you know
administrative staff they're
ordering animals they hear about it
they're involved in the field so there
still is a risk for everyone
despite if their job description
requires them to actually
touch animals or not
now there of course are some risk
factors which can predispose people to
developing compassion fatigue so i'm
just going to highlight a few of them
so people who work on a daily basis with
animals especially if you're involved in
a more
long-term research study that gives you
more time to develop
bonds with your animals um so that
increases risk
certain procedures or protocols people
just may not feel comfortable with and
may feel kind of a dilemma
in performing them sometimes euthanasia
would fall into this category
but also think about certain invasive
procedures like surgical models of
certain types
or perhaps the idea of using or using
death as an end point
so i especially think of researchers
themselves falling into that category
for procedures
and support systems are really important
for us to have for mental health
and that means that you have people you
can talk to that can kind of provide you
some compassion and care to allow you to
kind of refill your bank
and it's more difficult i think just to
handle emotional stress
and trauma if you feel like you're alone
now of course there's other risk factors
very much related to an individual's
personality
um and personal history so like
unresolved trauma
previously or really just an inability
to
communicate maybe their needs to others
those can all
you know fold into this so it's a very
you know individual
variations in how much people are
affected by this
um and i do want to point out that the
amount of time in this industry doesn't
really have any
sort of effect on whether or not you'll
develop compassion fatigue so people
can be relatively new in the field and
get it quickly or you can have been in
the field for decades and not have it
so it's a lot of personal variations
how can we try to determine if we are
suffering from compass fatigue
some there's some different ways to
categorize symptoms
um but one way is to break them down
into these categories of intrusive
arousal and avoidance so our intrusive
symptoms
are things like thoughts and images that
um kind of are intrusive into your life
they about the traumatic experience
these can manifest as things like
nightmares or just
you know you're out of work on the
weekend but you're still remembering and
thinking about
something that you saw and this can lead
to an obsessive desire to actually help
certain animals an unhealthy kind of
obsession with things
an inability to let go of work related
matters and
sometimes you can just start feeling
inadequate as a caregiver
the arousal symptoms these are things
that are changes in your emotional
response so
increases in anxiety and frustration and
anger
and projection of anger onto others
sleep disturbances is really common with
this especially because
these emotional responses change you
physically and you can actually get not
only sleep disturbances but what's
called
somatic illness which is where you get
physical effects of your stress
and so you can get sick easier you'll
have worsening of chronic diseases
potentially
and then finally the avoidance symptoms
kind of as it sounds
um you can get apathetic to things once
felt enjoyable
both at work but in your personal life
and hobbies as well
um people may start to feel like they
only
want to put in the minimum at work when
they used to feel a lot more passionate
about doing more um
maybe not feeling like they want to hang
out with their friends as much so
they're starting to isolate
um and this can progress to even more
destructive behaviors like
self-medication and addiction but
you know not just with drugs but things
like online shopping
gambling those kind of things can worsen
or develop
and then there's just another way to
categorize these symptoms by instead
mental physical and behavioral changes
so they're all basically what i just
mentioned
but just categorized in a different way
so just um you can see that
how they divided it up that way
so uh jim spillman she provides some
retreats and workshops for people that
suffer from cohash fatigue mostly
related to human
um healthcare industry but she had this
interesting trajectory of the
development of compassion fatigue in
five
phases that i liked so i was just gonna
quickly go over it where
you start out in the zealot phase where
you're really idealistic
or like keen and committed to
enthusiastic about work
as the compass fatigue starts to set in
you get those
emotional changes and irritability
cutting corners
having more oversights and mistakes at
work um
and then withdrawal so those are the
avoidance symptoms where you're starting
to isolate yourself from others
um not really wanting to talk about work
and
neglecting potentially people in their
personal lives as well
and then the zombie phase is when you
start putting kind of yourself on
autopilot in a sense
um and this is where more frustration
and anger sometimes can lash out
and the final result is some sort of
transformation that comes from this
so you can either undergo what's called
pathology and victimization where you
become overwhelmed you kind of just
continue
in this state and potentially just leave
the profession because you feel like
this is not for me i am obviously not
doing well here um but the other
transformation you can have is a
positive change
which is where you start to actually
recognize these symptoms
and start to make changes in our lives
and using self-care strategies
and manages some of these underlying
issues so when we
find ways to manage recognize our
stressors
and our satisfiers and find a balance in
our chosen career
that's what i hope we can all come to
so now of course why should we care i
think hopefully most people would
agree with me that caring for the mental
well-being of people in our profession
is important no matter what um but i
think that
we usually draw into our profession
people that do deeply care about animals
and we really
want to maintain them because that
promotes better animal welfare in the
end you have those
caring people that want that are
committed and enthusiastic
and they're just going to help drive our
profession better and better forward and
advancements with animal welfare
so we want to keep them in our field but
if you want buy in from leadership for
supporting mental health initiatives and
maybe you need a little bit more than
that
so i also think we should start framing
this as
a occupational health issue actually um
and other people agree with me um
so in the current edition of the lab
animal medicine blue book actually
you'll see that in the occupational
health chapter
they talk about psychosocial hazards of
what we do
and these pretty much line up with
compassion fatigue so it talks about how
the human animal
relationship and research is complex and
there could be some kind of
um psychological dissonance with the
idea of we have animals as pets maybe in
our home versus
animals that object as objects at our
work for
use i mean that can be difficult and it
mentions specific hazards like
desensitization to euthanasia or certain
procedures
and how all of this leads to anxiety and
depression and of course
all of these psychosocial hazards are
related to compassion fatigue
so i think it's really important that we
start getting our occupational health
programs to be on board um and our
institutional leadership to kind of
recognize it as a work
hazard in our specific profession and
actively work to strategize on an
institutional level ways to combat it
now of course that's a very slow change
that can happen over time and i know
you know some occupational health
programs don't in my personal experience
don't feel like they're equipped to deal
with this which i understand
if you don't have mental health
professionals in your occupational
health program
but i think it's something that we need
to start talking about and thinking
about it maybe this way so that over
time we can start
utilizing occupational health programs
as a way to bring in
compassion fatigue strategies
and also an institution should care
because
if employees are experiencing capacity
there is an overall noticeable increase
or noticeable effect on the workforce so
if you have a lot of effective workers
in your
company you're going to see decline in
morale and productivity um so
staff may not you know complete
assignments and texts
or meet deadlines on time as much
there'll be trends like higher
absenteeism because people are out
sick more um and they'll be higher
turnover rates i think that's a pretty
clear
one that people see in our field
sometimes and actually there could
potentially be higher worker
compensation claims because
with decreased concentration and
commitment you
can get higher levels of injury
and then decreased morale is a huge one
um
interdepartmental dysfunction goes along
with that your teams may not start
working together
together as well because people are more
irritated and
frustrated and quick to anger so um
and then the other problem is if
somebody new enters this environment
that's already
having people experience a lot of it
even with a lot of self-care it can be
really difficult to maintain a healthy
mental state just because of that kind
of cycle
that's already happening in the place
that they enter so
this isn't just a topic for individuals
to think about how we can help ourselves
but also a company to think about
how we can help our workforce to
increase you know
productivity
okay so what can we do about it um so of
course
um there's many ways to approach this
and i hope that i
and i'm sure some of you have had some
great ideas i haven't even thought of
but this is kind of based on what i've
done and talked to other people about
so um i think one step you can start to
do
is send out a survey to your employees
at your institution
and determine where they think the
biggest issues are and their ideas for
changes that can be made
to improve their work environment now we
did not do this in michigan
when we started kind of our compass
fatigue stuff but i've talked to
a couple of couple other places that did
this and
i think that it's really amazing because
you
may be passionate about it but you don't
realize some things that somebody else
at a different department
had ideas about how to improve stuff so
you can get a lot of generate a lot of
really ideas and interests this way
um so i think that was a really good
idea
um but increasing awareness and
education of the topic is really
important and that's kind of how we
started at michigan um
when you start talking about it and
employees start hearing about it it
does create over time a um
an environment that normalizes people's
emotional responses to working with
animals and encourages them to express
feelings free from shame and
embarrassment if they realize
oh it's okay that you can grieve over
animals in our work
so the more time more people talk about
it
i think people realize it's okay to feel
connected to animals feel compassion
and also then it gives people a better
chance of recognizing these signs
in themselves and if necessary then
start determining strategies for coping
on a personal level
so how you can start increasing
awareness can vary
we started by offering just a couple
educational lectures
for our staff so we made a general
announcement at our all staff meeting
about it
and then had some um more in-depth
lectures than to attend and they were
similar to kind of the beginning of this
presentation um
in terms of talking i did a little bit
more in depth about
um some signs and things like that
um and that these were put together by
me and another technician
so we're not experts by any means but we
became potentially experts so i think
anyone even if they don't think that
they can do it if you have an interest
and passion
um you can become the expert at your
institution
and give a talk on this and we also did
have a counselor
we came in during this time to talk
about personal coping mechanisms and i'm
going to definitely circle back to
counselors later
but we did include her during the
educational talk
now another way we implemented awareness
is with just like this poster
i worked with our office of research
communications to create and distribute
them into our animal facilities
and the goal was to disseminate
information not only to our internal
kind of
animal care staff but also to the wider
research community because
all of them could be affected so we want
to be able to reach
everybody as much as possible so i'm
just going to look closer at the
contents it's pretty simple poster
um we just wanted to have a statement
that emotional distress
can occur in this job and basically
showing that the university recognizes
this can happen
and then we put a link to the cost of
caring brochure
that's been put out by alas which is a
really great resource
about human animal bond and grief in our
field
and then finally we put our information
for universally providing counseling
services which i'll
also circle back to when i talk more
about counselors in the future but it's
information so it's easily accessible
for everybody
i mentioned the cost of caring brochure
i just wanted to show it here if you
guys haven't heard about it
um i recommend just look it up on the
website and download a copy of it
it's really great like very simple
addresses
the human animal bond in the field and
states that acknowledging
feel are feelings of animal care workers
and providing support in the workplace
is really important
and i like the statement that they have
in there that says if bereavement
is addressed appropriately individuals
will feel validated
their coping mechanisms will be
strengthened and their ability to
sustain new bonds
and form new bonds will be reinforced so
this is a great
uh resource that's why i included on the
poster because it kind of is a nice
summary
that's easy you don't have to put it
together yourself
so i encourage you all to look that up
now since all animal users are at risk i
think that
putting it in some in some information
about this in a required
training of some sort is a really good
step that everybody should go towards
um have it either in an online training
or in-person training however your
institution does it
i worked with our training corps that we
have at michigan and put some language
in our required animal training from new
users and i just put a little snippet of
it up there you don't have to read that
um but we already had a section in our
new user training called the dilemma
which really talked about the ethical
cost of using animals and research
in general so it was a perfect spot to
actually put in some information about
the emotional effect on humans as well
for um
and then also include the links to the
counseling services that are available
at the university
and we do have a required hands-on
training for our new rodent users
which um our trainers started to just
mention this as well during the
um the in-person classes and just uh
bring it up so again more we talk about
it with more
people start recognizing that it's a
thing
especially researchers you know graduate
students phd students aren't the ones
who usually come to a left
and those kind of meetings where this is
being talked about more and more so i
think it's really important to try to
reach
that population of animal users
and another option if you don't want to
come up with something yourself
the alas learning library recently
published this module and
i think it's great that the team that
put it together um agreed that
it should go into the occupational
health section of the training so that's
where you would find it
um and it's a really pretty short
one and it's a great uh resource to
start with
even just for yourself if you're
interested in learning more but also
especially if you're using the als
learning library for your required
uh training for your users already it's
really easy to just
add that in as a module that they should
go through
so i would really encourage everybody to
put something
in required user training either related
to compassion fatigue but even if you
don't want to use
that terminology things like using words
like psychosocial hazards or talking
just about
emotional costs of working with research
animals i think it's really
an easy way to bring awareness is put it
in some sort of required training
there's another way that you can kind of
evaluate compassion fatigue
individually and then your program is
this online tool that's out there
and it's called the professional quality
of life scale
and it's available for free online it
was developed by dr
figly and another researcher that can't
remember her name of at the moment
the language in there is veered more
towards social worker type professions
but uh catherine dobbs if anyone saw i
think in 2014 she gave a talk at alas
about compass fatigue
and she used this test and with the
author's permission
change the verbiage in the questions
more to geared towards
animals and she provided that to me for
free
and um so you can contact her or you can
contact me
i could get you that version of the test
um her name is catherine dobbs um
and it's a pretty short test you can
hand it out to employees
to do on their own time to gauge their
own qual you know their own level of
compass fatigue and compassion
satisfaction it kind of tests for both
the way i used it was at michigan we
just handed it out at our educational
lectures
for people to take home you know and do
on their own time but
if you wanted to use it as an anonymous
survey you could
ask people to fill it out and then you
know not no names so there's no
association with
anybody particularly and then you can
kind of have a sense of
how it is at your university what the
percent of affected people are
or institution i said university but
obviously not i was at a university
sorry
so once you've started to bring
awareness to what compassion fatigue
is what are the next steps that an
institution can take to prevent and
combat it
so personal coping mechanisms are an
essential part of managing work stress
uh burnout and compassion fatigue which
includes things like self-care and
mindfulness
and depending on where you work you
actually may already have a bunch of
resources available to you for this
if you're a medical school there
actually can be
resources for hospital staff regarding
capacity that are already there and
available for you
um our institution has
a really great hr program that provides
individual and
department kind of style workshops and
lectures on things like reducing stress
mindfulness stuff like that so those are
great that you can utilize
the trained counselors already for
and so i talked about how we had a
counselor come in and speak
uh during our kind of initial education
lectures
on self-care topics and we reached out
to our counseling program
and this is something really important
that i think i want to stress is
whenever you're going to utilize a
counselor it's important to reach out to
them first and talk to them about animal
research
the realities of what we do you know and
make sure that they're comfortable with
it because the worst thing you can do is
bring someone in
who has a negative opinion and you can
risk traumatizing people worse depending
on the reaction
you know the counselor so make sure that
they you know they have accurate
information about what your department
does
i mean it's okay to you know our
counselor said like ethically a
counselor has to
declare you know if you say hey what's
your feelings on animal research because
this is what we want you to talk about
they have to tell you
if they you know are vehemently against
it because that would be
ethically conflict for them to be
involved with that
so i think that's really important to uh
remember
um and just look at your resources this
is what i want to stress look into
resources you might already have
especially like luckily at michigan
we're a big university
so we have these resources available
already for us to start you know
actually tapping um however you
i mean i don't think there's any reason
you couldn't reach out to an external
counseling service and as long as you
find someone who's comfortable with
animal research is willing to come in
you can utilize the expert that way but
also there are
i found two research specific animal
research specific
consulting services that will travel to
your university
and do compassion fatigue seminars and
workshops as well
so these are people that are you know
obviously know about our field
and are involved in it
okay so mental health professionals say
that the cornerstone of the prevention
of compassion fatigue is actually good
self-care and so these are some of the
kind of stuff we talked about with our
counselor
and when she talked with us i'm
obviously you could go into huge depth
into this topic and i'm not going to um
but i just want to show that i'm not a
i'm not an expert on this matter but you
can find information out there and give
it to your employees
you know and talk about it if you're
willing even if you're not an expert you
know self-care techniques um
are important to just bring up and
mention so i was just gonna go over some
of these really important ones like
um very generally um so i think
everybody knows that getting enough
sleep is really important
and not getting enough sleep makes you
vulnerable to stress and compounds
physical ailments so
this is all gonna affect our compassion
fatigue levels
um exercise may be one of the more
overlooked
uh types of self-care because it's
actually been shown that exercise just
mild you know exercise can help combat
feelings of depression and chronic
health problems
um so thinking about maybe doing
something with
a group like with a making a walking
group for lunch at your institution or
something like that you can even make it
more you know instead of just by
yourself you can involve
a group of employees and things like
that um
proper eating and drinking so you have
more energy to deal with stress
um so finding your time finding time for
yourself every day is really essential
for your mental well-being
and going along with this is finding
ways to recharge your energy which may
be
things i mentioned like exercise or
meditation or
yoga um but really just the most
important thing i just want you all to
be aware of is that
making yourself a priority and setting
some self-care goals
that will work for you is really
important
and i really like that analogy so i put
it in here because the way that our
counselor described why self-care is
important in relation to compassion
fatigue and stress is that
everyone's it's the water bottle
metaphor so
imagine your stress and trauma kind of
levels like a water bottle
and everyone's ability to manage it in
our lives is different so everyone has a
different
size water bottle just naturally and
we'll fill it up
and we can handle our stress levels
until at some point
it's going to overflow you're going to
hit your tipping point
and this leads to those manifestations
of all the signs of compassion fatigue
that we've talked about you know like
changes in emotional responses as
outbursts trouble sleeping
but if we can decrease the flow of water
that's great but that's not always
possible right you can't always prevent
the stresses and things in your job you
can't change things
so in order to continue handling the
flow coming at you
you have to find ways to poke holes in
the water bottle kind of to allow
you to handle that amount that's coming
in and these holes are basically those
little self-care things that you
provide and you do and so i just think
that's a really nice analogy so i want
to share that with you
and something that is also a really good
idea is to have some sort of
transition from your work to your home
i flipped this picture because i think
the analogy is more
churning from superman at work back into
clark ken at home instead of the other
way around
um so for those of us who have
people at home like family or pets or
just roommates
sometimes as soon as you walk in the
door from work you have to start
caring for a whole new set of people or
animals
so since our jobs a lot of times require
actively caring for other people during
the day or thinking about living
creatures during the day
it can be really draining to go directly
from one to the next without stopping to
give yourself some time so this is
talking about that me time that recharge
and renewal
um so i think it's important to have a
transition period between the two
um and carve that out for yourself um
you could you know just stay in the car
when you get home for 10 minutes and
listen to an audiobook
that you wanted to listen to or whatever
um and then another thing you could do
is
more um kind of a symbolic way to put
away
the day is transition out of your work
clothes
into your a different set of clothes as
soon as you get home and you're in your
me space now and try to just
divide yourself from your work more
actively
and also if you have to do work at home
try to set a specific area
for your professional work separated
from the rest of the areas of the home
to kind of
continue making those symbolic
separations which can help your mind
separate them as well
and as the nature of our work can cause
us to sometimes
do things that we consider unpleasant
it's essential that you determine
if there's any things that you find
especially distressing
and you would consider off limits and
draw the line for yourself
and that could be certain species that
you can't work with
certain types of procedures or protocols
you don't want to work with
and obviously when you're applying for a
job you could look for a position that
meets those
requirements so you can continue work in
the field that you want to work in
while minimizing what's traumatic
specifically to you
um now in a current job that
you're in you may have some flexibility
to allow you to decide that lines but
not always
you know obviously understand this is
something you would hopefully do but
it's not always possible
um and i just i want to bring that up
for people that are supervisors or
managers
think about that with your employees if
you have the ability to help them be
flexible if they come to you and
kind of be open to listening to them or
recognizing when there's something maybe
stressful and there's a way that you can
do things like work sharing or you know
community at least especially
just communicating with them so i think
something really important is
communicating about animal endpoints
and giving people the the opportunity to
be present
or not present for maybe an end point
for an animal especially
a one that they've formed a bond with
don't just assume for them that they may
not want to be there because it's just
stressful maybe they need that
to say closure or they want to be the
person that's there
because that allows people to help form
their own coping mechanisms for
things that we do that can be traumatic
so i think it's important especially for
supervisors and managers to consider
how much you communicate with your
employees about things like that and
just
being flexible as you can obviously it's
not always possible
now i mentioned before about support
systems and this is
really important as a coping mechanism
and something that we can actively try
to do in our jobs
so something that's really unique in our
field i would say
is a lack of social support we get for
what we do so i think everybody's pretty
aware animal research can be a
controversial topic
and i'm sure many of you have actually
experienced negative reactions when you
tell people what you do
and sometimes that means you don't tell
people what you do i've had that exact
experience myself
um so and because of that then you're
less likely to share with others maybe
something that is traumatic to you and
so we don't
talk about it and um you know i
so i like to think about it like this if
a firefighter has experienced something
really traumatic
you know helping somebody you know and
they had a traumatic experience
they can talk about it with somebody in
the community and they are feeling like
a hero because that's how they're viewed
and so they get that support from the
society saying
you know you're a hero your job is
amazing you know what you've done
and so it helps them re-energize it does
help
to have that external support but we as
a industry potentially don't have that
um now this leads into a whole topic
about transparency in our industry
and how we can work to actually grow i
think a better social support system
uh with through openness and
transparency and there's definitely some
talks
just coming up recently about this topic
exactly
um if you're interested in that the
americans for medical progress
organization is something really great
to look into obviously that's not what
this topic
topic is about or this talk but um
i think that uh it is something that we
can actually work as a
um as a field to actually kind of grow a
better social support network by being
open about what we do and i'm sharing
the amazingness of biomedical research
everybody understands um
so friends and family i i didn't
actually um
haven't talked about friends and family
yet so in that same vein
because they um
friends and family may not understand
what we do or you know you don't want to
share with them what you do
you they may not be the best support
system for specifically for compassion
fatigue in our field
they may be you know but if you don't
have friends and family um you may need
a different
kind of support group available for you
um so i discuss counselors and i want to
talk about
how useful i think counselors are so if
your institution has internal counseling
support available
i think number one it's essential to
make sure your employees know about it
because i found that a lot of people
myself included didn't really realize
that we have a support system with
free counseling available for people
that work at our university
and so a lot of our animal technicians
didn't know about that either
so we worked with our counselor at the
service to make some informational cards
to put into our
staff break rooms and this is the front
of the card that she put together with a
little quote from a merc
research laboratory memorial service
that they had
which is really nice and then on the
back information on the employee
assistance program so
making sure people are aware of the
resources that are already there is
really important
and then something i am also especially
fond of that we can do
in our industry is a peer support group
so we started one of these
at our at michigan uh that occurs once a
month
and the meetings are a time for people
to come in and
discuss specific issues you know for
others to offer support
suggestions to each other um really you
can structure these
kind of support groups however works
best for your place of work
um and me and another technician kaylee
bennett she and i
you know became the facilitators of the
group we didn't you know
lead it per se but we found that the
biggest thing that we had to do as
facilitators
was to try to keep people on topic and
prevent it from becoming just an
unhealthy rant session because there is
that tipping point between
trying to be helpful when people are
sharing about problems versus just
you know venting about the job until it
becomes a circle of everybody's venting
and then now you've made a negative
emotional
experience and so you kind of have to
try to hold that balance of okay well
let's try to give some positive
feedback or you know support
um and then something that i really like
that we did was
people that came we would ask them to
come up with a self-care goal for
themselves and then
check in uh throughout the meetings
and give each other accountability so
that you can't just say oh i should do
that and then you never
make any changes because everybody does
that so it's kind of nice to say okay
this is what i want to do and then
next time maybe you didn't do any of it
and so we can ask you what can
is there a way we can help you motivate
you so i think that that was really
important
so i think this next topic here employee
engagement is one of the most important
for preventing compassion fatigue which
is really connecting with the purpose of
what we do what we do so when someone
can connect
with the difference that they're making
in the world because of their job
it can help them understand how
important they are which really helps
with employee engagement and job
satisfaction
um so people really need sometimes help
remembering
what drove them to enter this field in
the first place
um now although many on the animal care
side are not directly involved in the
research
uh they're obviously we know an
essential part of the process
and sometimes people need to be reminded
of that especially by
connecting them with the research
outcomes of the research that you know
they
did help at ground zero basically help
happen
um and this sense of purpose increases
morale
and retention of workers and we know of
course animals are greatly benefited by
having a caring and compassionate worker
force so we need to keep these people in
our field engaged
in our field um now the human animal
bond
is what connects us to the animals we
work with and
i i want to make sure it's clear that
like some people would say that if
somebody's experiencing capacity fatigue
then maybe they just
you know shouldn't like work with
animals but i think that we need to
encourage the human animal bond because
it's important to form bonds with the
animals we work with because that's why
they have such good care
it's our emotional investment in the
animals that we care for that propels us
to advocate and work for their
well-being
um so you have to find a way to strike
the balance between being emotionally
invested but not
so emotionally attached and that's very
hard balance to strike but i think
um and obviously that's you know
something that talking to a counselor
might help
in an individual way but i think
self-care techniques
as in connecting with your purpose of
doing what we do
allows people to kind of continue to
renew those emotional resources and
allow them to form bonds over and over
and continue having that caring
passionate compassion for animals
over decades of time
so talking about connecting employees
with
the research side of things um there's
ways that you can do this for instance
we have a program where we have research
seminars with
investigators coming in to talk to our
husbandry staff
and share their work so that way we can
bridge that divide
that sometimes happens especially in a
huge institution like michigan between
researchers and husbandry staff
and this way employees can hear those
specifics about amazing outcomes
of research that's happened directly
with the animals they may have been
changing cages for
and i think that that really helps
bridge that divide
and another more passive way you can do
it instead of an active seminar
is through newsletters so we have a
monthly animal care and use
program newsletter which has research
spotlights every time with
amazing research that's come out of
michigan so you can read about for
instance here
why especially bred rats that you know
maybe
somebody was like oh i changed cages for
this lab you know these
you know these animals led to increased
knowledge about the connection between
exercise and endurance capacity and
heart attacks um
so i think newsletters are really great
so how else can we keep employees
engaged in our field
something that i think maybe sometimes
is overlooked is actually empowering
employees to be involved in decision
making
especially those that may feel on the
animal husbandry side when they're you
know lower down the
authoritative totem pole they feel like
they don't have any input into
decisions being made about animals at
work um
so we have an animal enrichment
committee at michigan that i think is a
great way that we empower our employees
we invite everyone from all over the
department to participate so it doesn't
matter
if you are an administrative staff or a
husband or worker anybody can come
and this committee was started very
small you know
not less than a decade ago and it has
grown to be
basically a very essential part of our
animal care program
um it generates ideas that we can
investigate
and you know validate and test and
implement and there will be a talk
i don't actually know if it's already
happened i hope not but uh jenny jones
are an animal enrichment coordinator is
going to speak about this
um in depth today i'm not going to dwell
on it too much i just want to bring up
as a
possibility of i think it's really good
to actually come back compassion fatigue
to think about these kind of
engagement um and just a few things that
the enrichment committee has actually
done
in terms of not only the people that are
on the committee
themselves but even the wider community
they engage employees and researchers to
do stuff like recycling glove boxes for
our
rabbits and rodents and milk jugs for
our pigs so that people can feel like
they're actually directly contributing
to the enrichment program if they
even if they don't come sit on the
committee um
and then they've also done really
amazing things like fundraising
um in order to have money targeted
specifically for the enrichment
committee
for the enrichment program and then
you know i've talked about
administrative staff something that was
a pretty amazing
idea i thought was this farm-to-table
herb garden program
where admin staff could grow herbs on
their desks that then we would harvest
and actually feed as enrichment to some
of our animals and so that was a way to
have people feel like a positive
connection to the animals that they're
working
around and for but never even see which
i think
was really nice program and then
something really important is our
um subcommittees on certain special
topics that
have formed to take on more complicated
issue which gives
some technicians opportunities to take
lead on various issues
talking about that empowerment it allows
people to grow
and um you know because of one of our
technicians
sarah thurston who's also talking she's
super passionate about our
about pear housing rapids now she is
pretty much an expert
and the lead on our and created a actual
um
position for her for rabbit social
housing here so
you know it is a great way to empower
employees to even grow
in their own careers as well um
and allows our technicians to feel kind
of that renewed sense of purpose
um and also better our field
and then the last topic i'm going to
discuss today is the use of animal
tributes or memorial events to help us
remember animals
that we've used in research and thank
them for their contribution
and this is kind of where i talk about
like those outlets for
appropriate artists for grief um so it
gives people
um a way you know a safe space to share
stories and
you know actually grieve and talk about
their emotions
and this is a great way to validate
normalize feelings
um for those that do experience it um
and can then therefore combat compassion
fatigue
and the tributes excuse me can be actual
services
or you can dedicate maybe like a statue
or a plaque or a garden space or
whatever you choose
to do and actually there's been quite a
few places
that have been doing memorial events for
decades successfully
and i encourage you to look up this 2002
isler article by susan iliff
about this subject called the fourth or
additional r
remembering the animals and so you can
see here this is a list that comes from
this article that just talks about some
of the places that have been doing these
events already
um and i know other institutions have
recently implemented some of these kind
of
events um and i know one for instance
was able to get a patient to come speak
at their event to talk about
um how their life was saved due to
medical advancements because of animal
research
so that direct pace you know from bench
to bedside kind of connection
um so i think that was a great way to
connect everyone who attended with the
purpose of what we're doing
and so if you can have some kind of
connection like that that would be
really great
um there's an example of susan had in
her article which was about um
this korean food and drug administration
actually has a pagoda outside of it
on the grounds of their main facility in
seoul and every year they have an animal
ceremony to honor the lives of the
animals
i think they started in 1983 doing that
so this is just a nice little
plaque that's basically a pagoda but or
you could do like a plaque like that
and actually the first known commendary
of activity in north america that
focused on animals
um was held in guelph university of
guelph in 1993 and i just wanted to read
a little quote from the text that they
said at that event because i really
i really liked it i love this i like the
sentiment that it has and it says
we are causing animals to be born
causing them to live
through a variety of unusual experiences
and causing them to die
this is a form of power that cannot be
taken lightly
today is an opportunity to acknowledge
the animal's role in what we do
to acknowledge that without them our
research and teaching would be
fundamentally altered
to thank the animals seems logically
inappropriate because their contribution
was taken
not given yet we are grateful for and
even dependent upon their role
i just think that that is a really
interesting way to frame my own
feelings on the use of animals and
research and i think it's really
important to
acknowledge um and thank them for their
role in what we do
at michigan something that we've been
doing in kind of a memorial sense is
using these memory boards
uh so for the past two years we've been
doing a science of enrichment symposium
and we've provided cards for people to
share
stories just names or a picture of an
animal
that they would like to honor and then
we display them which has really
been very well received we've also given
out
paper seed hearts for people to write a
name on and take home and plant in their
own garden
for to create maybe a memorial garden
and this year's
enrichment symposium we're hoping to
actually provide some
flower bulbs for people to take home and
plant
we also use these memory cards we have a
different version of them
that we put at our department booth for
an annual university-wide research fair
so this was allowing anyone who came by
the booth
so you know people that actually worked
with our department but also researchers
from all over campus could come by
and contribute a card and then we would
display those throughout the day so that
was a great way to also try to
involve our research staff in this
now our we have a compassion fatigue
committee um
at you michigan and we started to work
to develop our own
official memorial event um which we
would like to frame as a celebration
more than a memorial i like that idea
that
um we would use it to highlight research
accomplishments that have come out of
the university of michigan over the last
year
and then also talk about advancements
for our animals themselves so things
that
about our like rabbit social housing and
dog social housing programs
now funding such an event can be
difficult we are
hoping to partner with our larger larger
office research to utilize
funds and therefore make it not just an
internal departmental style event but
actually an event open to the entire
research community
again trying to reach not just our own
our own field but
um researchers outside as well
and some other ideas that have come up
that you know we may or may not be able
to do
but i think it's good to talk to other
people about these ideas is you know
having some sort of
art dedicated that um is either made we
even talked about having animals make
the art like if
we could get um non-toxic paint
and have the animals walk across paper
and then make that kind of art that you
could display
and dedicate or if you have outside
space potential
you could secure a little spot of it you
could plant a tree or put a plaque there
um have a place for maybe specifically
for quiet reflection time
so overall i think that animal memorial
ceremonies are a really
wonderful way to keep employees engaged
in their job
and create this culture of openness and
discuss the idea of compassion fatigue
and the human animal bond
and function as coping strategy
so to conclude today um i have shared
ideas to try to combat compassionate
in our industry i believe we must first
make sure that there's an awareness of
the topic
and then provide resources regarding
individual coping mechanisms
and consider how we can provide support
systems to others
especially if people don't have external
support systems as well
we really need to work on engaging
employees to promote increased job
satisfaction
helping them remember the importance of
why we do what we do
um and then provide some sort of
memorial activity or
tribute um for celebration um even as an
opportunity to express
grief and i hope some of you may be
inspired today to implement some changes
at your own institution
and be the change that i believe our
profession need
so i just want to thank everyone for
their time and attention today and you
are
free to contact me i will do some a
couple questions right now
and you can contact me with any other
questions uh
if i can't get to them i wanted to put
some acknowledgements up here
um people at the university of michigan
that i've worked with kaylee bennett
jennifer jones um jenny lofgren and
sarah thurston have all been
involved with the compassionate stuff
there and sarah thurston's taking over
as our
compassion boutique committee uh
chairman as i'll be leaving
my residency uh in the next six months
and then i also wanted to put up
two people that i met at the universe
just last year
uh preston uh who is going to be doing
an als
webinar on compassion fatigue um and
adriana pavin from ohio so they've been
implementing some things and they have
they're great resources as well um for
doing capacity stuff so
i would encourage you to if you know
them to talk to them or reach out to
them
um so yes thank you very much
and we'll do questions now i believe yes
and thank you miriam for the informative
presentation
and inspiring work and culture you've
created in your lab
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question drop down box located on
the far
left of your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at the questions
already coming in from our audience
members
our first question graham is what was
the biggest
hurdle you encountered getting started
uh great question so um i think the
biggest thing
specifically at michigan was we're a
huge institution
and you know with a lot of employees and
we were going through a lot of
change when i was trying to start up
something
and a lot of people were experiencing
work burnout
just overworked and so that was
difficult to get
people to actually even care because
there was like i'm overworked i don't
have time to try to come to some lecture
or do a peer support group because they
don't have time in their day so that was
that was definitely difficult
um and i think it was just a lot of
persistence
on the part of me and kaylee to say we
really want to um change the culture
here and so it may be a kind of slow
going but
um just kind of slowly being like okay
we'll just keep offering the peer
support groups and keep you know
bringing it putting it on our
um you know employee newsletter
so that everybody knows it still happens
when we started to get more people
interested in attending
um so that definitely was a big hurdle
is getting people to
realize that they should care about it
as well
and i want to also thank our audience
members
for their questions today we have a few
more here and any questions that aren't
answered today
will be emailed to you um in the future
our next question what are some
resources that you recommend to learn
more
about compassion fatigue
question so um i actually do have here
a couple more slides that i didn't show
you right here at the end um
with some resources so
i think that i did mention of course the
alas learning library so i'd recommend
for sure looking at the capacity fatigue
module
also the american veterinary medical
association
as uh you know recognizing of course in
our kind of general
um practitioner veterinary side that
this is a big problem
so they have a whole web page so if you
google and look for the work and
compassion fatigue page on avma
they have a lot of great resources about
it
so i'd mentioned catherine dobbs she's
the one who had changed
professional quality of life scale
wording so she has a website as well
at katherinedoms.com so that's uh she
has some great resources on compass
fatigue
and you know she came and spoke at alas
so even though some of them are more
geared towards
general veterinary medicine you know she
obviously understands our field
and then there's the compassion fatigue
awareness project
which also has some great resources that
kind of compiles it all the website
there
if you're interested and then i did
mention the consulting services
before and i did put up their
information here um
so i met uh the lady uh annette
anna k kaiser from cope plus at alas she
was there and she
has created this um counseling kind of
um
consulting service specifically for
people in the animal research field and
so she
i know worked with preston at the
university of washington
doing a kind of a needs assessment with
them so they're
great she's a great resource to reach
out i know preston really liked working
with her
and then the animal research consulting
company at animalresearchconsulting.com
i just found online that they offer uh
workshops and like uh seminars
they'll come in and talk about
compassion fatigue specifically uh so
those are the two kind of consulting
services that if you
want to reach out to an outside expert
they're really great uh
to go to
thank you we have time for one more
question
what's one piece of advice for someone
who wants to start compassion fatigue
initiatives at their own institution
all right great uh great question
i would say the biggest thing is
trying to get you know
more than just yourself because you want
to have a sustainable program so you
don't want it to rest on just the
shoulders of
one person who may be leaving for three
years from there
you know after the residency is done you
want to make sure that there's a group
of people that
can you know be interested in this so
finding
some interested people and forming a
committee
so that you can you know help each other
and make sure that that i think it's
really important is to try to make sure
that there's people from a lot of
different
places within the institution so you
know
having from the veterinary side the
business office side
you know your husbandry technicians or
your trainers
and that will give you a lot of
different perspectives that i think
are really important to kind of craft a
program that'll meet a lot of different
needs
is that getting a lot of those
perspectives of how is this
you know what kind of things would be
the most beneficial for husbandry
obviously
may not be the same for veterinary staff
so
i think that that's a really good thing
you know to do is
reach out and find people that you can
kind of coerce into saying hey this is
really important let's
let's meet about this so that you also
have that accountability to
and you know drive to go together if
everybody's like
interested because if it's just one
person it can get overwhelming and
hard to start things and you may feel
like oh i can't do this but
um and then obviously i mean if you only
ask for one piece of advice but i would
say you know
reach out to people at other
institutions too you're not alone if you
want to start this obviously you can ask
me
you can ask preston um there's so many
people out there that have started these
compassionate initiatives from nothing
to making it something so you can do it
but you can always reach out to other
people that have done it before um for
advice and just support to feel like
it's
you know it's it can be slow going and
that you can feel
um you know you can feel discouraged at
times sometimes
but i think it's so important that we
need to keep talking about this in our
field so
yeah beautiful thank you
and i want to thank you um again for
this presentation would you like to
provide
any closing remarks for our attendees
today before we
close down um i guess i'd just like to
say
well thank you all for you know sitting
here and listening to this and i hope
that you learned something and i really
hope that
it did inspire you that you know this is
something that um
we need to start considering more and
more that you know
we need to care about the mental
well-being of you know ourselves
in this profession because as i've said
obviously throughout this that
having people that remain positively
engaged and can continue forming bonds
and feel compassion that obviously is
only going to help
increase the animal welfare because
you're having more people that are
you know wanting to promote animal
welfare
and keep those people in our field i
think it's really important that we
don't lose
those people that are so passionate
about it because they get overwhelmed
with the emotions that maybe they didn't
expect to experience because
nobody told them and then they felt like
they were they're wrong or it's abnormal
like no nobody else is feeling this
maybe this is weird and maybe i
shouldn't be in this field
because you know nobody talks about it
but you know and i personally have
experienced that in the beginning of
this field that people didn't talk about
it
so i think that's important just to say
hey oh it's okay you know you're feeling
grief because that animal was euthanized
that's okay that you know so just
um continue talking about this and
i hope that all of you will talk about
this at your own institution if you
don't already